all right sam yes sam where'd you grow
up where are you from originally uh i'm
from uh rural new hampshire a town of 4
000 people um
i lived there until my early teens and
then i moved to uh
south pasadena but on the edge of
northeast l.a i come from a life of
upper middle class extremely white
privilege
i come from a very
culturally
the
not diverse place like uh
my grade school was a hundred people one
was puerto rican everyone else is white
i came to los angeles my brother and
sister are much older than me
12 and 9 years apart
they were born in the 60s i was born in
the 70s and they moved to california as
adults and i visited a few times i got
the bug and once they had children we
immediately moved out here and
as soon as i moved out here uh
it was an intense
culture shock to say the least from new
hampshire yeah and i i have like i said
i come from an upper middle class life
of privilege um
world traveling i've you know been to
england 13 times we'd go every summer
my parents are all artists as are my
brother and sister visual artists that
being said the privileged thing comes
from the socio-economic aspects of my
life
nice you know never had to suffer got
all the stuff i want
dark side of that is
my mom and dad are both workaholics my
mom comes from an extremely
horrific
childhood of abuse she's an extremely
traumatized deeply disturbed individual
my father is
was uh in the asperger's spectrum but uh
you know had 160 something iq um
he had a three degrees english teaching
and fine arts
um
and a hyper intelligent person uh but
that being said i experienced extreme
neglect um and severe
physical violence at the hands of my mom
my brother
my older brother when i was you know
pretty much since i could remember
my earliest memories are flashbacks of
being brutally assaulted from the age of
two and on
and um
my brother was a monster
and you know he he lives a life of
extreme privilege again i'm not gonna
say who he is um they've gaslighted me
my entire life to make me think i'm a
bad guy but i extreme experience
extremely violent
uh beatings daily sometimes three times
a day
every day
until i started physically fighting back
around age 11 or 12 probably a
combination of puberty and me finally
get taking martial arts lessons
and uh i just became an incredibly
violent person um because that's how i
was raised and i actually sought help
from adults uh teachers
um
uh you know uh even
doctors things like that and the
response because it's i'm born in 1978
the response was then don't be a baby
don't be a tattletail or they would just
deny it and then i would get severely
uh corporally or corporally punished
after the fact and so i just realized
that no one had my back
i was rejected neglected not taken
seriously
so
once we moved to california
the first people that were nice to me
were
chicanos mexican americans
and
you know
that world
i didn't realize how dangerous the world
that i was
stepping into
a lot of it was involved in the punk
rock uh sort of scene but you know the
the their
punk rockers have cholo and chola
cousins and brothers and you know
sisters and stuff like aunt aunts uncles
parents grandparents and i found that
lifestyle to be
attractive to me because
one thing that i think is very important
and that people don't understand is
people
have this stigma about gang members
being selfish and self-absorbed and and
you know they don't care about anyone
else and how could you
there's a massive thing is one of the
most important things to understand when
you're dealing with gang members and
people involved in criminal
organizations
is that you're dealing with people
that can be
usually 99.9 of the time have
experienced tremendous physical sexual
and psychological emotional abuse
i feel like i i may have repressed
memories i don't
yeah and and these are people that have
been completely rejected by their
families or not necessarily rejected but
hurt by someone and maybe unbeknownst to
their major guardian or parental unit
like well i don't understand every
everyone else is such a good kid blah
blah blah for example my brother and
sister are vanilla as as it comes you
know what i mean they are wonder bred
corny ass white people and um
and they uh have no tattoos um they're
square you know they're artistic you
know they're already people
uh they have a little bit of a freaky
side to them as far as like aesthetic
goes but they're square you know my
sister's never smoked a joint in her
entire life my brother did drugs for a
couple years got caught stopped
um i've been uh but anyways i'm
digressing um
one thing i would say it's very
important thing that i think people
would help people understand gang member
and gang mentality criminal mentality is
that especially with gang members is
you're dealing with people
that are egomaniacs with no self-esteem
that is one of the most dangerous
combinations of a human being that you
can get for example myself
uh i'm a i i i am working on it i've
made tremendous breakthrough through
eight years of tremendous amounts of
talk therapy without the aid of
prescription medication i tried here and
there it made me violent worse punching
holes in the walls but tremendous
amounts of tactile to work through this
really
intense uh
just
overwhelming narcissism that stems from
uh no self-esteem
i never planned to live past 40 i'm 44 i
i live life as if i was i didn't i was
once i learned 40 i was like oh my god i
can't believe i [ __ ] lived this long
you know uh i wasn't planning on looking
like this i wasn't planning and ending
up like this i i kind of was just gonna
either fade away or go out in a blaze of
glory
and i lived my life and made my choices
accordingly and uh
another thing um
we we you know touched on this before
but uh
there's a distinction i i've been
involved in three different types of
gang activity
one being at the um
during it's it's a punk rock
scene phenomena it's a thing called uh
sh arps which stands for skinheads
against racial prejudice
it's very very hard to get that into
people's heads that what skinheads are
not racism but yes initially in the
1960s skinheads were not racist it was a
reggae-based culture where they were
emulating
west indian jamaican culture as those
two cultures existed side by side the
poor working class white and west indian
culture in
london in part different parts of
england and then during the 1980s uh
when things became
enormous amounts of unemployment
etcetera etcetera then the white
supremacist aspect came into it uh with
the national front in england and i'm
not going to give a whole history lesson
on it but
what sells is hate and fear not a bunch
of guys that are into reggae and like to
dance and dress weird and shave their
heads what is interesting is a bunch of
scary white guys with their head shaved
with swastikas that's what's interesting
and that's what gets the public
uh that's against the public eye and
it's funny because
99 99 of people that call themselves
skinheads are not white supremacists so
anyways again i don't really want to get
into a history lesson with that but that
is uh as i started off as um
punk rock is what appealed to me i like
that i grew up with that that's the
music i was exposed to
as a kid
my brother and my sister it was a goth
and uh
that was the thing where i still felt
weak i'm like i didn't want to be a punk
rocker i wanted people to fear me i
wanted people to respect me so i became
a sharp
um and it quickly got involved with
gangs with that and then the thing with
sharps is they're about fighting nazis
neo-nazi people that skin heads um
and that
also gets very complex because at the
end of the day it's not no one really
has your back fear is god and uh
everyone turns on themselves one way or
another and it comes down to who's the
most popular it's just like an alpha
male contest you know and again back to
the
uh egomaniacs with no self-esteem again
which is a very dangerous world to live
in and ultimately
can be fatal and doom doomed for failure
once i started getting into drugs i you
know i smoked weed from when i was about
12 and i started getting into drugs
mostly lsd
and uh mushrooms
uh i tried speed when i was 16. this is
methamphetamines wasn't really
a thing yet i mean it existed but it
wasn't as violently
overwhelming as it is now
there used to just be speed
uh it was white it wasn't crystal it
could have been any substance i did that
that made me feel kind of super human
and you know i could dance and party and
hang up and talk over everyone else for
hours at a time and
eventually
that started to become a problem
started doing it all the time every day
and then you start to develop toxic
psychosis and paranoid delusional
schizophrenia based on that stuff
and then i
got involved that the the skin the sharp
lifestyle didn't make sense to me
because it didn't involve money it
didn't involve drugs and i didn't i
couldn't work because of my mental state
was so ravaged
so
what i did eventually uh is i knew gang
members in a particular mexican gang in
um
part of northeast l.a area and again i'm
not going to say who but i got involved
with them
took me in very quickly and it was all
about money drugs and power
uh and then once uh i got off the rails
very quickly as my uh amphetamine usage
got worse and worse and worse i was
literally doing it every day
uh i had a hard time telling what was
real and what wasn't um
and eventually uh i ended up uh
a friend three or four of my friends uh
this other gang member um he sexually
assaulted one of our friends
sisters
um and uh traumatized her sexually so
bad that she became a non-verbal
disassociative schizophrenic um
catatonic schizophrenic is the term um
and he was proud of it and then we
basically
exerted vigilante justice upon the sky
put him in a wheelchair in a colostomy
bag everyone got we fled the scene
everyone got caught but me and you know
i don't i don't snitch even though
people will probably say i'm snitching
just by talking about this but hey
uh and uh i did the time and
the way our system works as a first-time
offender i'm a white guy
so you know i got a attempted murder
mark down to aggravated assault and
battery uh i played the white guy card
and i got a year and a half in la county
and because of overcrowding they knocked
it down to six months
and uh
one thing
a tremendous
crashing down of my loyalties and what i
understood to be how things worked
was when i entered the prison system as
a mexican even though i'm a white guy as
a mexican gang member
the first thing that happened is i went
to go eat i went over to people i
literally knew from high school some of
my friends dads and uncles and even one
of my friends grandfathers and i said
hey what's up guys
they said you can't sit with us and i
it's like what do you mean and they they
said uh you got to go sit with the
peckerwoods the white boys and i and i
have this visceral hatred for them as a
former anti-racist nazi hunter
essentially
and i'm considered what they call a race
trader um because of that
and uh or lame or whatever and uh
i was like i'm not [ __ ] sitting when
those guys were like well you can't sit
with us man i'm sorry in the streets
it's different but in here this is a
completely different world we love you
we got your back but sorry man take a
[ __ ] walk
and then i just went and sat by myself
and then the white supremacists came up
you know big nazi guys giant swastika on
his face probably like almost seven feet
tall like a monster you know something
that looks like something like an extra
from game of thrones minus the armor
and uh they came you know what are you
doing over here by you know by the
[ __ ] or whatever
and i was like [ __ ] you guys
and i knew i was gonna get assaulted so
i attacked a guy split his face open
with my lunch tray
and the last thing i remember is just
being
pummeled into unconsciousness and when i
woke up i was handcuffed to a drainage
pipe
in some the bowels of l.a county
and it's probably one of this is
probably the top three most traumatic if
not the most traumatic events of my life
where they had a
german shepherd snarling and biting an
inch from my face tearing my clothes off
they were beating me with sticks
their night sticks like that they
electrocuted me several times
physically kicked me with their hands
and feet pepper sprayed me an inch away
while i was literally handcuffed to the
wall
or the pipes sorry
and then uh they
put me in a
solitary confinement cell and
this is important to the story is i have
uh what it's called severe
severe uh moussophobia and if you don't
know what that is it's fear of rodents i
have no idea why um i think i just saw a
lot of
rats get caught in traps as a kid and it
really
[ __ ] me up but
they put me in a cell naked
pitch black and rats would crawl all
over my body and bite me and i believe i
was in there for two weeks and they
would throw food in there and
immediately the food would get swarmed
by rats
uh i had to drink out of uh this
disgusting
like fetted toilet water
the thing in the back didn't work
and i was uh same height i'm six feet
tall i weigh
100 and 210 pounds now i was
135 pounds when i got out of there i
looked like
a concentration camp victim and
it brought me out and one thing that
they did
is they'd have a thousand watt light
bulb in the hallway to literally blind
you intentionally and i couldn't see for
30 minutes it was bizarre being
white white blank like not darkness it's
just white
and it took about
six hours for my vision to go gray and
then back to color probably by the end
of the day
and then
later on
they had me doing some basic work in a
kitchen
which is not very common but they kind
of wanted to separate me and the next
thing i remember and this is uh
two weeks later so i was in there for a
day that happened two weeks later
probably a couple days later
and i was washing dishes and i felt this
bizarre pressure in the side of my neck
right about here
and then i remember leaning over the
sink and my hearing went out i couldn't
hear anything
and then all i saw was this it was my
vision went black and white and all i
saw was this
brown it looked like chocolate syrup
swirling
into the uh
drain and then the next thing is i woke
up and i was shackled to bed and they
said i had uh
my heart had starved three times i had
lost
more blood than they'd seen anybody lose
in their entire life but it didn't
puncture any lymph nodes or anything but
apparently i got stabbed five times in
the neck with a filed down toothbrush
and that's just the information the
nurses are sharing me could be true
could be not
but
they said it was so expensive to keep me
in there and because of the overcrowding
and this is in 1997.
i was so overcrowded they just let me
out
that was it i did three months and uh
you know i i did not not three months
but i did
i was in the coma i was in a coma for
let's see
they said two to three weeks or
something like so a little over a month
uh five or six weeks and again it's
i'm not clear on that but i got out of
jail and i was so traumatized from that
i i felt like as if i was a skid row
person where i was walking around like
what are you looking at what you look
[ __ ] you may know like this bizarre
bizarre fully
kicked in
paranoid delusional psychosis and
everyone's out to get me don't look at
me i'll [ __ ] kill you
and within a week i was back in jail
it put me in solitary confinement again
it [ __ ] me up even worse uh they let
me out after
uh two weeks in solitary this time i had
lights at least and then they let me out
and then three days later i got arrested
again for attacking someone on the
street because i thought they were
looking at me funny uh right around this
very right by a union station and then
the third time they were like uh if you
come in here again we're really gonna
kill you and
i managed to
stay with the right people who kept me
away
from
going back into this and just kind of
let me rage out in their garage and flip
out and just pretty much 24-hour watch
to me and uh within a month or so i kind
of like calmed down
and then it wasn't until after that i
started doing uh
mdma because i have been self-medicating
my entire life
mdma with a combination of lsd mushrooms
here and there
and it was like as if someone took a
squeegee to my brain
um i
had i completely let go of all this like
what i was just one of those like what
the [ __ ] have i been doing type moments
and
but i was still
so involved in i had lived that
lifestyle for so long where why could i
why am i going to work this minimum wage
job where i could go rob this liquor
store or i could go rob this other drug
dealer or this or sell drugs and pretty
much a it's a it's a horrible lifestyle
but it's just something huge risk ma big
payoff
type thing and i basically you know have
worked stupid jobs being a bouncer here
and there
um just to have some sort of like
taxable income so to speak but i've
basically been a drug dealer
criminal uh
you know robbing other drug dealers so
to speak etc pretty much
until
i met my wife when i was 37-ish
uh no wait 40-ish 40-ish i kind of
realized like tried to phase out of it
so when i was like 40-ish i met my wife
um she completely
she she's the first person that i felt
really loved me
unconditionally and
i realized had to stop doing what i was
doing
my father passed i got an inheritance so
i didn't have to live like that and then
during this time period i started seeing
a psychologist um
and i would go to talk therapy with this
guy um
one to five times a week and it was just
one of those things where the first
first time someone a stranger had my
back and trust i could trust i i've
never been able to trust anyone he
led me to believe and it took a lot of
convincing and proof
to make me finally trust this guy and i
realized that
the reason i became the way i became was
the horrific physical psychological and
verbal abuse i experienced at the hands
of my family members who are supposed to
be the people that love me that way and
the people i should trust and
um i and
yeah that was that a combination of
their enormous amounts of talk therapy
um and then i had a child um
two and a half years ago
and even the moment i found out my wife
was pregnant was the moment where is
like i was still a high-ranking um
shot-caller i had got back into the
anti-racist
um
nazi hunter scene again and had
just i'm not going to say the state but
i i had moved from california and
established a chapter
um and clicked up with some other
anti-racist groups
and created a sort of
an alliance with them
or a firm or a crew or whatever you want
to call it a click
and
i
you know heavy is the head that wears
the crown and you live in a state of
constant paranoia because you're a
target you have to make examples of
people you
have a lot of pressure even within your
own group
and you're always in a constant state of
vicious paranoia
and
you know my neck hurt it felt like i had
wearing a thousand pounds around my neck
um
and all this sense of uneasiness waking
up you know sleeping with a gun under my
pillow waking up with panic attacks and
who's outside and you know and things
like that and what's this guy [ __ ]
looking at and
uh you know it wasn't i kind of was
doing a half-assed job of running things
once i started meeting my wife and i
think it was our first wedding
anniversary
a little over two years ago
i was just having this horrific kind of
meltdown where i was having to deal with
this stuff because i was a shock caller
and the founder of this chapter um and
uh
i was like on our wedding anniversary i
said i'm gonna quit you know fingers
[ __ ] crossed and nothing bad happened
to me but i was ready to expect a severe
physical uh you know jumping out of and
because i had put in so much work in my
age and my amount of time of you know
20
12 years specifically with that
particular organization um
i was allowed to walk off
and that was incredible and i still live
in a state of paranoia but that was over
a year ago now and i've been
non-affiliated or i'm a lame or whatever
but um
and i don't care there's nothing those
guys can say to hurt my feelings i have
nothing but respect for them
um
and but i did what i had to do you know
and uh therapy
meeting my wife hair pregnant having a
child those four things
are what solidified
my mental state into you know destroying
this
very toxic very dangerous narcissistic
fatalistic i don't care if i die i don't
care who
who goes down with me i'd have a code of
honor you know hurt children women
you know uh
old people kids whatever animals like
that i have a you know a code of honor
um you know i'm not i'm not a psychopath
you know but um
but uh
it's just it's
it's incredible to be free of that you
know and and it's still something that i
have nightmares about and i i still live
in a state of fear and paranoid i don't
walk anywhere without knife in my pocket
you never know you know
and that's something i have to live with
for the rest of my life so
it sounds like love is what
changed you yeah um that's it love uh
having
never experienced love
and someone who just loved me because
they loved me
and someone who believed in me and
believed i was smart i was told i was
stupid every day by my mother for my
entire life
and when someone tells you that every
day you start to believe it but i i
i still have horrific self-esteem issues
i still have body dysmorphia issues
um
i still have a lot of self-loathing a
lot of self-hatred um
and it's something i'm working on i work
i'm working on it like it's the cure for
cancer you know uh
and uh it's hard but with the love of my
wife and the unconditional love of my my
daughter
and you know i'm her hero um you know
and she it's uh
that's love really you know not
cheesy or cliche but love really does
conquer all love is stronger than hate
but at the same time
um human beings the root of the human
being human experience is fear and fear
is more powerful than love unfortunately
you can say whatever you want and i
agree love is obviously the best but
there's also fear associated with what
if you lose that love what if you're
afraid if someone doesn't love you
that's the scariest thing in the world
it to me is if i lost my wife or my kid
if you know and again legally i have to
say this i'm no danger to myself or
others and i'm not gonna harm myself but
if i were to lose my wife and my child i
would kill myself
i have nothing to live for you know um i
had made it this far and they're
they're the light that that that keeps
me alive you know even when i have my
dark moments and you know i'm diagnosed
with severe
post-traumatic stress disorder um
manic depression uh social severe social
anxiety i had to take xanax just to get
down here you know
um
and uh
uh you know uh
uh manic depression uh post-traumatic
stress disorder um the list goes on you
know um
and
i've conquered a lot of these things but
it's it's an everyday battle and it's an
uphill battle at times and some days are
worse and sometimes i can't leave my
house for a couple days and sometimes
it's hard to take a shower and then
sometimes i feel like i'm on top of the
world and indestructible but that is
what is what makes manic manic
up and down
i i assume you'd say your childhood
formed all these problems that you
yeah
100
yeah you are a product of your
environment you're a product of your
child and that goes back to the thing of
the people saying you know nine nine
times out of ten the gang story is oh i
had a horrific childhood i grew up in
poverty
i chose to live that life i chose to
live on the streets i felt
being
i was homeless for three months you know
i i
i felt safer
living in the gang culture on the
streets carrying a firearm being
harassed and assaulted by the police and
living in this
nightmare world because that nightmare
world
was a better alternative to the
nightmare world i experienced within my
own family
and it's very strange i felt
safer and happier living
in a world of constant physical
threats of violence and and terror
because the emotional and psychological
abuse i experience daily
and i don't i i've completely severed
any communication i have to to my family
because it's
it's it's not safe they're not safe for
me to be around they don't respect me
they fear but the life you built for
yourself as an adult matched what you
experienced as a child yeah i created
this world because um that's the world
that i had control over i was the master
of violence and that's another thing is
um
i'm a martial arts expert um i'm not a
master or whatever but i've been doing
martial arts since i was 11 years old
i'm certified to teach
two different styles more but i don't
practice those anymore and actually
that's one of my legal sources of income
i've had since i was uh
19 is being a martial arts instructor
and that is one of the things that's
made me such a dangerous powerful person
because in the gang and street culture
being skilled at violence or being
extreme if you're not physically as able
to handle yourself with or with without
weapons
um you know you got to use a gun you got
to use a knife you gotta you know how to
know how to manipulate people use power
get people to do things for you but i
found out one of those things is that no
one ever really had my back so i i
delved i went head on into martial arts
and uh
i can fight you know and it's not
whether it's like oh i'm [ __ ]
invincible or whatever i'm just speaking
from personal experience and especially
as someone who's been a bouncer where
you encounter
anywhere from one to sometimes five to
ten really intense life or death fights
at night vet weapons involved and i've
lived that life for a really long time
since i was 21 years old
i can i i have no physical fear of any
other human being in a one to one or
even three to one sometimes five to one
situation
um and i i know what i can do i put a
lot of time into conditioning my body
and training my body which also
makes my per my paranoia and
all these other things makes me that
much more of a dangerous person because
with or without a weapon and with the
weapon but even without a weapon
i know i could kill people with my bare
hands and it's not something like i'm
proud of it's just something i am
confident that i can do because it's
it's i've done
i've seen what i could do in real life
everything i know i can do is because
i've really done it you know um i've
broken people's jaws shattered their rib
cage caved in their faces and you know
i'm not i'm not proud of this i'm not i
i have a conscience about it and you
know looking back most of the time it
was uh self-defense
um and you know 99 of the time i never
did nothing and nobody didn't have it
coming to him or wasn't asking for it
but there's been times where i've been
in dark places where i just didn't like
the way somebody was looking at me and i
took it to that level and that's uh
that's something i have to live with for
the rest of my life and i
really wish i could apologize to those
people
so if you see this i'm sorry if you know
who i am and i don't know who you are
but i'm sorry
um but uh
you know one of those that's life life
is uh everything is chaos honestly i
used uh i studied buddhism pretty
extensively
and have for a long time as it kind of
goes hand in hand with martial arts but
um
people say oh is that karma and i've
actually heard that on some of the
things you say oh karma karma is a thing
the karma you know there is no such
thing as like oh i have karma or that's
your karma karma is is the effect is the
law of effect
the fruits of karma
are what happens
when you when karma happens
for example you know you do this i slap
this guy in the face he slaps me back
that's the fruits of my karma or he
doesn't you know
bad things happen to good people and
good things happen to bad people bad
guys win and good guys lose my father
got parkinson's when he was
38 9 years old and as a illustrator he
lost the use of his right hand and then
he had to teach himself how to draw with
his left hand and then he got brain
implants and then had to do that and
then had to take 23 pills a day and
eventually be went insane from toxic
psychosis and i got to watch this
profound
genius kind man deteriorate into a
demonic
product of toxic psychosis induced
dementia and he never deserved it he
never did nothing to nobody you know and
that's that's that is what i believe
everything is chaos and all you can do
is try and be kind
including yourself but for me being kind
of myself is
one of the hugest
struggles that i deal with on a daily
level the way i treat myself internally
just even in a dialogue sense or
monologue sense or whatever
i would never speak to
someone i care about or even strangers
the way i speak to myself inside and you
know it's something you have to be aware
of but my god man easier said than done
you know
all right sam thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem
fascinating okay no problem thanks
you